Oh
you
hello everyone and welcome to part 2 of
our webinar series on 3d culture and
analysis getting started in 3d setting
up your lab and reviewing common
pitfalls of researchers new to 3d I'm
Alexis Krause of leverage and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lappers the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsor please visit thermo Fisher comm
let's get started you can pose questions
to the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left your screen
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button questions will be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window click on arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer
question box located on the far left
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credit please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. mark Kennedy
Rd scientists at Thermo Fisher
Scientific cell biology 3d models for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
mark you may now begin your presentation
thank you for that introduction and
welcome everyone who's taken the time to
join us here today for this presentation
titled getting started in 3d and so my
goal with this presentation is really
aimed at people or scientists who are
new to working with 3d cell models or
people who perhaps have not yet decided
to start working with three mob 3d
models but are very much interested in
doing so and are just looking for some
some information on practical
considerations for moving into this this
new area of cell culture models
so just briefly what I plan to cover
well we'll start with just a very light
introduction to 3d cell models I'm also
going to talk a little bit about some of
the common reagent that are used as well
as point you towards some of the
available resources that exist on the
thermo Fisher website or elsewhere that
really may help point you in the
direction of identifying what it is you
need in order to get started or to help
you choose what what model might be best
for for answering the questions that
you're most interested in addressing
after that I'm going to talk a little
bit about a couple of it says here
common techniques but perhaps they that
should be on common techniques just some
information about some differences that
that you will very quickly run into some
of which that are probably self-evident
but regardless if your background has
been primarily or only working with
traditional 2d monolayer cultures there
are some not subtle but but there are
some things that you will run into
quickly that will protect may present
challenges to to newcomers to 3d cell
models and lastly we'll just talk a
little bit about some of the other sort
of almost advice points or tips and
tricks and things to be aware of for
people who are interested in exploring
or moving into more of a 3d cell culture
workflow
so with that I would like to start by
just briefly mentioning or introducing
people to go to the wonderful world of
three cell models as many of you I'm
sure aware this is an emerging field
right now that is really drawing a lot
of interest across a wide range of
research areas it's really been climbing
in the prop prominence over the past
decade or so with the publication of
several key or seminal findings only
just a couple of which are highlighted
here in the graph on the left and these
these represent some of the foundational
pluripotent stem cell derived or adult
stem cell derived organoids models that
are really helping propel 3d models
forward and as you can see here this
graph is a representation of the number
of publications being published year
over a year for the past couple of
decades and you can really see here that
really driving the interest here people
from from all areas of cell biology are
are taking advantage of the new things
that 3d models has to offer to sort of
break that down a little bit on the
right side of the screen here of the
slide this is a simple breakdown of this
PubMed search just to give you an idea
of the types of tissue models or disease
models that are our most heavily where
researchers are most heavily using
different types of 3d models cancer
today appears to be probably the field
where 3d models are having the largest
impact early on however there are many
other tissue types in which 3d models
are allowing scientists to ask new
questions about development and disease
in a way that they've not been able to
do before
and so really there the use of 3d cell
models is becoming quite ubiquitous
across all walks of research
so when we say a 3d cell model at least
for the purposes of today's talk what
we're referring to really is a cell
model in which you've got an aggregate
of cells so as opposed to traditional
model air culture where cells are grown
sort of well in mono layer on some sort
of flat surface the 3d models tend to
take advantage of aggregating cells in
one format or another or using bio
printing for example to create complex
three-dimensional structures from cells
that allow them to make these advanced
cell culture models and and somewhere in
between the two are some various
co-culture models as well as the micro
physiological systems or the the organ
on a chip type approaches where in some
some instances these may appear more
like a 3d saw models in other instances
they're a little bit more like a tissue
engineering of a 2d model layer but
regardlessly these all represent some of
the different flavors of 3d cell models
that that are growing in popularity and
for today's talk the the emphasis of the
information that I'm going to give
although it's not limited to spheroids
and organoids that will represent the 3d
models of focus so for most of what I'm
talking about and I'll refer to them as
we go
usually I'm going to be talking about
steroids and organoids
as a 3d model
and one of the places where I like to
start is with some definitions so so
this is an area where definitions are
still somewhat unsettled in the field
and you you may have yourself differing
definitions here but again for the
purposes of today's talk so that when I
say a spirit or an organize you
understand what I mean even if your
definition doesn't fully align because
there are areas in which this
terminology really becomes a little bit
hard to follow sometimes but for our
purposes anyway a spheroid is really
just an aggregate a 3d aggregate of a
cell line or primary cells that self
aggregates into what almost looks like a
ball of cells really
and these spheroids the cells in these
spheroids are able to grow and
proliferate and they may display some
altered or enhanced physiological
responses compared to their 2d
counterparts however kind of what you
put into this model is all of us ever in
there the cells may grow and proliferate
but there's no differentiation or or
change of cell types that that really
happened so in other words there's
really no stem cell compartment to to
these models however when I talk
organoids what I'm really talking about
is a stem cell derived model and so
these can be models that are derived
from other pluripotent stem cells such
as embryonic stem cells or induced
pluripotent stem cells or they can be
cells isolated from from tissue adult or
embryonic tissue in which a tissue
specific or tissue resident population
of progenitor or stem cells are able to
self organize into little micro tissues
that resemble the organ from which the
cells were originally isolated so and
this is in line with with some published
definitions around organized and this is
a snapshot of one here that that we like
to use for a way of example
so there are many reasons why
researchers are moving in the 3d cell
models this table is just meant to
capture a few of those reasons it's
becoming more and more recognized that
although 2d models have been and will
continue to be very useful in for
certain applications they are very
simplistic and as it relates to drug
discovery for example the over
simplicity of these models is often
cited as one of the reasons why
traditional 2d models are not very
predictive of a cell's response to a
given toxic answer or some form of
compound and so 3d cell models however
appear to be giving a more in vivo like
response in many cases and in some
reports are seen to recapitulate more of
or behave more in line with clinically
relevant data where available so some of
the considerations here between 2d and
3d cell systems that may help one decide
if which model is right for their
question is looking at some of the
things like the culture conditions for
example conveniently in 2d model air
culture cells are uniformly exposed to
the cell culture media which means
anything that you put in the media all
cells are more or less uniformly exposed
to them whereas in 3d systems really
only the cells on the outside of the of
the 3d model is exposed to the full
concentration of any given compound and
so this sets up diffusion gradients
across the 3d Micro tissue and this has
impact for its biology and we'll come
back towards the end of this talk with
with another note about that
some of the other things that you may be
aware of or that you that is good to be
aware of is that 2d systems often times
is the gene expression or the protein
expression signatures of these cells
don't correlate terribly well with the
signatures of the tissue from which they
were originally isolated or in the case
of a patient derived cancer
they don't always or in fact usually
they don't look much like the tissue or
the cancer or the tissue of origin one
of the nice things with 3d cell models
is that this they seem to hold the gene
expression signatures or protein
expression signatures much more
faithfully such as they look more like
the invivo tissue or disease sample
compared to tuning systems however
although this sort of enhanced biology
if we can call it that is a great
advantage there are other things that
sort of are standing in the way are
currently limiting 3d systems in terms
of their more widespread adoption and
the ability to scale up some of these
models for for more high-throughput
workflows and that leads to things like
the the lack of validated assays for 3d
work clothes
while many assays can be sort of
co-opted for use in 3d there tends to be
a lot of optimization that one has to
use now since most of the available
assays were developer for 2d cultures
and so there is some consideration that
one has to take therefore for optimizing
assays and it also because there are 3d
is tends to be a little bit of a or
somewhat of a low throughput for for
various types of imaging analysis for
example that may require cryo sectioning
or paraffin sectioning as opposed to
simply labeling the entire model layer
culture so there are challenges like
that that that new scientists to the
field should be aware of and this kind
of relates also to the complexity of the
model in that although 3d models are
more complex than normal 2d models this
also makes them somewhat technically
challenging to to grow to handle and to
assay
the good news is that all 3d cell models
start with the same foundational pieces
that also culture models start with that
is they require cells they require some
sort of vessel or substrate to grow on
or in and they all require some cocktail
of media and or supplements and growth
factors or the like in order to grow and
proliferate or potentially differentiate
and form these different tissue specific
organized models
so just for point of reference here so
some ways of example of this so that
cells that that are commonly used today
a lot of them are stem cell our stem
cells are their pluripotent stem cells
or our various IPS C cells that have
been reprogrammed from patients for
example making and you know using
patient derived cells as well as various
cancer cell lines but there's also a lot
of people using various types of primary
cells such as primary human hepatocytes
and I'll come to this I think on the
next slide as well many of the culture
vessels and matrices that that you're
already familiar with also are used in
these work clothes
these include matrices such as gel
tracks which is a essentially a basement
membrane like extract that that's used
as an extracellular matrix mimic or
there are other scaffolds such as the
algae matrix matrix that give Co
currently offers and as well as other
things like like collagen there are also
many models require the use of plastics
that prevent cell attachment so that the
cells basically grow in suspension and
the use of these super low attachment
plates such as the knuckle on Spira
micro placer and fishes and flasks are
also very useful in culturing various
types of 3d models and like I said many
of the median supplements that I'm sure
many of you are already aware of things
like the stem flex media or the
essential 8 media for for culturing
robust stem cell cultures and other
common or popular basal cell media
formulations such as the air PMI 16:40
media advanced mm F 12 medium and and
various others and supplements like b27
and various flavors of b27 and of course
lots of different growth factors
the other things that can be used for
for analyzing these systems then are
things like high content analysis
platforms as shown here on the top right
but you can also do more standard type
approaches as well where these cells can
be taken RNA isolated for doing qPCR
type analysis of gene expression
signatures or of course cells can be can
be isolated and other more sequencing
type technologies can be applied to
better characterize the cell population
and also using sort of more standard
hopped wearing fluorescent microscopes
that are more benchtop like instruments
such as the the Evo cell imaging systems
and again many of these can be
interrogated with a lot of the reagents
at least looking at cell health can be
interrogated looking at a lot of the
reagents that are are commonly available
through molecular probes as well as
there is antibodies and labeling kits or
the use of pac-man assays for example to
through the characterize what you have
in your 3d cell model system or if there
is a an alteration in the cell health of
your model you can also monitor that
reasonably effectively as well with
different types of cell health or
viability kits that are that are
commonly available
as I mentioned or you know a lot of the
cells that are currently in use today in
3d cell models includes things like
primary cells so these include things
like endothelial cells which may be used
for modeling vasculature but also
primary human path sites or and other
animal hepatocyte other animal
hepatocytes as well or these under non
inherent conditions can also form
aggregates or spheroid like cultures and
this provides some advantages that 2d
cell cultures simply don't have for
example with respect to hepatocytes one
of the traditional challenges with
working with primary human of pata sites
is their longevity in culture so in
typical 2d cell culture a good lot of
primary hepatocyte only last for
probably somewhere around four to six
days a really good lot or with some
special media that are available that
might be extendable towards to more of
eight ten days or so but simply
culturing hepatocyte that in a spheroid
culture immediately provides you
advantages to to the longevity of this
model as as it's been shown by by
scientists at thermo Fisher as well as
various other places that spheroid or
hepatocyte spheroids can be cultured for
many days in many weeks allowing
scientists to study other features of
drug toxicity low turnover compounds and
things that weren't weren't very easily
achievable before 3d and of course
there's the widespread use of stem cells
such as IPS CS which can be gene edited
to make disease models or if their
patients arrived they could be used to
make isogenic line for preparing
controls and disease models for for
studying disease etiology in a 3d cell
model
so this table is also just meant to to
summarize some of certainly not all the
landmark publications across a number of
different organisms and again just to
orient you to to the fact that many of
the the cell culture ingredients that
that you may have been using for other
purposes are often have often been
directly co-opted for form any 3d model
systems so these includes many different
basal media like I alluded to earlier
advance team MF 12 is certainly a very
common media used across the adult
organoid model systems as well as neuro
basal and traditional DM MF 12 in
various other IPSC derived models and
and there's a whole host of different
recombinant factors or growth factors
that can be used to help direct the
differentiation all these pluripotent
stem cells so that you create the the
orbital model that that you're actually
interested in making so that it contains
the cell type sets that are relevant to
you and many of these are currently
available today
one of the things that we hear a lot
especially for people who are just
getting started is again looking for
resources to to help identify what
reagents help them plan since these are
lines tend to be very long experiments
having the availability of reading these
resources is very important for for most
people that that we talk to and this is
an example here you can go to the thermo
Fisher comm / 3d models website for more
information and for all of the things
listed here this is just meant to be a
highlight of the website or of
information from the website just just
to let you know that you know there
there's lots of information on this
website and also in many other places
that you can find with a simple google
search to help you identify protocols
and the methods that may be used as well
as you know if they're currently exist
in foreign thermo Fisher for example as
these are existing products there tends
it's organized in a way where things are
easy to find to help get you started
there's also technical resources that
are available freely these includes
things like application notes that and
scientific posters that to help show you
how internally in NRD we've been using
various reagents in different 3d cell
model systems and in some instances
there are also some how-to videos that
we've put up from collaborators to help
people get started in certain model
systems and this website is by no means
a sort of one and done it's certainly
something that is being continually
updated so if you are choosing to work
in 3d cell models remember to
periodically check back as there may be
new information relevant to to what
you're interested in studying and
allowing these lines this is a couple of
last things here other resources that
are available for people to to download
our things like there's we have an
e-book centered on cell culture and
analysis as well as the standard
molecular approach
handbook which contains many of the
different molecular probes that can be
used to to assay various features of
cell health and there's also a very nice
elearning course that you can freely
register for and there I believe a bunch
of modules and just to sort of take you
through the history of 3d cell models
and and some information on on different
types of 3d cell models that you may
find just very informative
so with that in mind one of the things
that I'd like to briefly start with is
talking about models or organized models
in particular that start from different
types of stem cells and one of the
things that one of the features that is
also self-evident here is that the
quality of the material you start with
is extremely important and you may hear
phrases such as garbage in garbage out
and I think that really applies to to
these models in part because they do
tend to be very long protocols and so if
you start with stem cells that are
poorly characterized or growing poorly
or have some routine culture issues you
really are setting yourself up for
failure and so in view of that I think
it's really good practice to remind
oneself to really take the time and you
know periodically characterize
yourselves make sure that they are of
sufficient quality to make it worth the
the investment to move into a 3d cell
culture model because these do tend to
be reagent intensive protocols so one of
the things that that's useful to do
shown here across the top and this
applies the pluripotent stem cells as
well which are cartoon on the bottom
left but if you're working with stem
cells it is good to periodically
characterize the the chromosome number
of chromosome abnormalities to get a
sense for what the genomic stability of
your system is that there there aren't
some chromosomal abnormalities that may
be contributing to aberrant
differentiation methods so that when
someone else tries to use a given method
on their own cell line they get
different information than what was
published so it's really important to
characterize your cells the general
mixed ability of yourselves this can be
done doing things like area stat you can
also do various techniques for studying
copy number variation just to get us and
also somatic mutation rates just to make
sure you know once you've taken
yourselves into
culture system that these models remain
fairly stable and don't start
accumulating rates that are sort of more
common than they are in other 2d cell
culture systems and of course doing
regular mycoplasma testing as well is
sort of a standard in cell culture but
also important is to remember to do and
as it relates to pluripotent stem cells
checking to make sure the cells really
are your population of cells really our
pluripotent is very important so that
you don't have some colonies of
differentiated cells mixed in with your
on differentiated cells that that may
make it difficult to reproducibly
generate the the IPS C model that that
you're interested in so that in other
words you don't have competing cell
populations or populations of cells that
may influence your model in a non
desired way and so monitoring
pluripotency of particular stem cells
can be done in any number of ways
including using commercial test such as
Claritas or the attack man based pac-man
scorecard system can also be done by
looking at immune ascetic chemistry of
various pluripotency markers such as och
4 and and Nanog and others to really get
a good sense and make sure the bulk of
your colonies are indeed in the
differentiation state or
undifferentiated state that you want
them to begin before starting your
experiment
some of the other things too to be aware
of it and I alluded to this earlier on
is that these cell models are
three-dimensional they're not that
they're not really in the appearance of
in sort of a X&Y
kind of arrangement there really is
depth of these models and so the
thickness of these models also creates
gradients of various types across the
micro tissue this includes things such
as gradients of oxygen and nutrients and
growth factors that are in the cell
culture media and so in a 3d cell
culture model these are the cells on the
inside of your spheroid or your
organized see the highest concentrations
of these things and as these molecules
are as you look across the diameter of
these models the exposure of cells
towards the center to oxygen and
nutrients decreases and this of course
sets up somewhat of a pincer a gradient
of carbon dioxide and various other
metabolic waste products that will
accumulate then more towards the center
of of your model and in some cases when
a model becomes too large this creates
or results in the creation of what
people usually recall a necrotic core
where the center of your organized or
your spheroid is eventually just dead
tissue or dead cells other things to
remember drug exposure would follow the
same thing cells on the outside of your
model system certainly exposed to higher
concentrations concentrations of a given
compound or ourselves towards the middle
tend to be exposed to slightly different
concentrations and for people studying
toxicology you know this can result in
differences in the types of IC 50s or EC
50s that you may be looking to
characterize for a given compound and in
in some reports this is thought to be
somewhat of a good thing because in V
so all cells are not uniformly exposed
to compounds in the same way and at the
same concentration so in some ways this
gradient is meant to mimic and be though
a little better there as well in
addition to this there are other
features to be aware of so I mentioned
in the product core and I'm the very
opposite of that so on the very outer
region of the asteroid model is where
you tend to have a proliferation zone so
cells on the outside tend to be more
prolific of themselves on the inside
which tend to be a little bit dead once
once a spheroid reaches a certain
diameter for a lot of cell lines that
that tends to be in the 250 to 300
micrometer diameter range and as well
there's are sort of a middle layer of
cells which are not really little but
they're certainly viable and
metabolically active and so just to give
you a real-life example here of on the
chronic core this is a spheroid grown
from fg2 cells which are hepatic
carcinoma cell line and you can see here
these these are labeled with a lesser
probe called sullivan caspase-3 7 which
lights up a pop tonic cells and you can
see here that a concentration of the
dead and dying cells in the center of
this spheroid
other practical considerations that you
may be aware of but but it's important
not to underestimate is the method of
aggregating your cells in order to make
a 3d cell model system some of these are
K can be thought of as either specialty
plastics or or perhaps non-standard
platforms in some instances and in other
cases they can just be kind of
cumbersome although we affect those
butBut cumbersome kind of approaches to
aggregating cells so on the top left
here is an example of what we call the
hanging drop method where literally you
you put a fixed number of cells in a
small droplet of media on a plastic
surface and you turn that upside down so
that it creates a hanging drop and this
results in the sort of aggregation of
the cells toward the apex of the drop
and where they are able to self
aggregate into to a spheroid this can
also be achieved and somewhat more
easily in methods such as on the right
here where this is meant to illustration
of a single well in a 96-well you bottom
super or non-adherent plate so these are
plates in which the inner surface of the
culture well has been coated or treated
in some way that a prevent cell
attachment and so when you put
yourselves in they all aggregate to the
bottom and the the shape of the bottom
there the shape of the well at the
bottom forces all the cells to kind of
aggregate together more quickly and
again this often for many cell lines and
cell types this results in the formation
of a spheroid
other types of formats that are used to
make or to aggregate cells other cell
lines or pluripotent stem cells or also
for long-term culture of them are things
like mini bio reactors or spinner flasks
these are things that you know you may
not have as a standard cell culture
vessel in your cell culture hood I'm
sure most people are probably more
adapted simply moving plates that all
look the same with different numbers of
wells or dishes of slightly different
diameters in and out of their incubators
but you know many bio reactors or
spinner flasks they use a magnetic
impeller which means they require a
magnetic plate or magnetic stirrer plate
to turn the impeller to help sort of
move the media around and some of the
reasons why this is done is that while
it may also help improve spheroid
formation as well as consistency in the
size of the spheroid it also the
agitation is also thought to help better
feed some of these spheroids so trying
to mitigate the effect of growing too
large and forming the chronic pores
which may not be desirable for for many
cell models it provides advantages there
and then so what comparable to that
although less commonly seen would be the
use of roller bottle cultures which
would would effectively be doing the
same thing but probably just a less
common approach in the literature from
what I've seen
so in keeping with some considerations
for spheroid growth if you're interested
in making spheroids from cell lines or
various types of primary cells typically
you don't need any special media using
what you've already been using a usually
some cocktail of DMM or D mm f 12 with
some field bovine serum
reagents that reduce contamination such
as and stress additives or auntie auntie
or premise on or other other types of of
reagents to help reduce contamination
issues and supplements you know glutimax
thing things that the cells like and
growing these in one of the format's as
shown on the previous slide is really
all you need to do to get started from
any cell lines and also simply for
aggregating for growing many cell lines
it gets a little more complicated when
you're working with pluripotent stem
cells the media may become a little more
specialized the use of growth factors
specific growth factors may become a
little more may become a little
different but otherwise you know this is
kind of the basic set up here so
this is meant to illustrate sort of the
last line with that is that
traditionally I know when I first
started culturing stem cells or to form
Android bodies from stem cells many
years ago one of the ways in which it
was commonly done partly because it was
cheap and somewhat effective was simply
to to culture cells in static culture
but in vessels that were not adherent so
that cells without attach and over the
course of a couple of days cells would
either aggregate and form or through
simply through through self-liberation
what would form spheroid but they would
form skewers of many different sizes and
the size of the spheroid can impact how
well it differentiates and the health of
spheroid a versus spheroid B if there
are different sizes you know these are
things to keep in mind and so some of
this can be controlled through the use
of formats such as you bottom super low
attachment plates or spare plates
in which fixed number of cells can be
put into each well so that it forms a
spheroid of more or less an own size in
a fixed period of time and so the graph
on the bottom right here is just meant
to illustrate that the consistency
between eight replicates of spheroids
form from four different initial seating
densities and just to show that you know
consistency and thorough size from
spheroid to spheroid is quite consistent
and the size of the overall spheroid you
know is directly proportional to the to
the number of cells that you start with
and so again these are important
considerations for for folks who are
just getting started
one of the other things to keep in mind
and I know speaking from personal
experience when I first started working
in 96
well you bottom plates it was a little
bit of it was a little bit of an
afterthought when I was getting started
as the how was I going to change the
media and this is important because
these are essentially suspension culture
so as we said they form because for
aggregates formed because the internal
surface of the plates are treated so
that cells don't attach and so this
means if you want to aspirate your media
you're also going to aspirate yourselves
and so the there are several ways to
sort of minimize this risk one way that
I find useful is to use multi-channel
pipettes of course if you're working in
96-well formats or you're probably
working with multi-channel pipettes
anyway but you can manually do media
changes usually it's done by not room
trying to remove the entirety of the
media but perhaps doing success of 50 or
75 percent of the volume removing that
and adding it back to the sort of dilute
the spent media until you just have
fresh media this is an effective way
however you know it still comes with
some issues of being consistent and
being able to hold a multi-channel
pipette level for a fairly long period
of time which sounds trivial but in
practices is not always and so you can
end up with inconsistencies in volume
across the place so although it is
effective it still it can be a bit
tedious and slow and it is certainly not
without some some limitations another
way around this has been the use of a
plate washer system so so it's a way of
basically automating your your spheroid
media changes so micro plate washer such
as the the well wash Versa has
controllable settings so that you can
control the position of the aspirator
nozzle as well as the speed of the
aspiration and the height of the nozzle
within the well so that you can eat
we program this thing to aspirate your
media without losing any of your
spheroid and if you like it of course it
can add your media back or if you want
you can you can do that part by hand
depending on the number of plates you
have it may or may not be needed but
it's certainly a much more efficient
facet and in our hands has been a very
reliable way of very quickly aspirating
a fixed volume of cells across you know
a number of 96-well plates and with a
level of consistency that i we were just
not able to do with multi-channel
pipettes very easily
so another thing to be aware of is that
many of the three cell culture models
especially on the organized side of the
three cell model Spain is the use of
extracellular mimics or matrices for for
growing these models and so these are
used to sort of encase the cell
aggregates in order to help promote
further maturation or some of the
structural organization that people have
reported and are commonly seen in
various types of organelles culturing
you know the ECM is a very important
component of that of that system so
using materials like Maitre gel or or
gel tracks which contain many of the
components that are normally found in in
extracellular matrix their matrices are
really useful in in helping promote
various types of model systems however
these materials are temperature
sensitive meaning you you have to be
careful you have to work with them under
conditions that are sometimes hard to
keep sterile so keeping things on ice
for example so that the ECM mimics
doesn't polymerize while you're working
with it so trying to keep your materials
cold while you're you might want to keep
your plate pre-warmed so that as soon as
you deposit major gel or gel tracks on
to the surface helps promote the
polymerization quickly so that the the
droplet or the dome of Maitre gel in
which you resuspend it selves you know
polymerizes quickly so that it doesn't
lose its shape and basically just become
trapped in what looks like a coating on
your plate and so this is commonly used
for growing certain cell lines as well
as patient-derived cells and various
types of adult stem cell organized
models
and just by way of example here so this
picture on the top left is an example of
three domes of an extracellular matrix
mimic in which cells have been
reconstituted so that they can grow into
steroids other multiple spheroids or one
spheroid depending on the model system
and what the cells were like before you
resuspended them in the matrix one other
thing that that's important to point out
is that these materials are also quite
viscous and so in order to pipette
accurate accurately with these materials
it's definitely a good idea to work with
positive displacement pipette instead of
the air displacement pipettes which are
probably a little more standard in most
cell biology or molecular biology labs
it's shirts certainly plays dividends in
pipetting the exact same volume from
from droplets to droplet which can
impact how how these things are being
fed so adult stem cells are grown in
this way where cells isolated from
tissue are re suspended or reconstituted
reconstituted inside of an exerciser
matrix and many of them grow into what
almost looks like bubbles inside the gel
so they form these cystic like
structures but if you actually stain
them with something such as Daffy you
can see that there is these cellular
[Music]
models these are lighting up all the
different nuclei representing all the
different cells in a given model shown
here on the right but this is this
really only works if you're growing
cells inside of an ECM another way in
which ECM is used which is maybe a
little more common or commonly seen in
the pluripotent stem cell space and that
is to either to take aggregates or
previously formed aggregates of cells
and to put them inside droplets of of
Maitre gel or gel tracks and so the red
arrow here and the picture on the bottom
is actually showing a spheroid of a
growing organizer should say that is
differentiating into
a certain lineages and at a certain time
point we have to work very quickly and
keeping the temperature sensitivity of
the material in mind try dispense or
deposit spheroids in sided droplets and
position them so that when the gel
phlegm arises there they're fully
encased so that they can then go on to
grow into whatever model system you're
looking at the picture shown here on the
bottom right is just a picture of a of a
neural organoid and you can kind of see
around the edges here a lot of the
almost like folding full of epithelial
egg structures although the center is
pretty dark suggesting that the center
probably will have a lot of dead cells
and this is not to on too uncommon and
certainly something to keep an eye on
when you're monitoring B the health of
your system
so as I wind down here in the last
couple of slides a couple the other
things that are probably relevant or
important for for people who are looking
to get started in 3d or who are only
recently started in 3d is that these
model systems tends to take very long to
grow so some of the cell line model
systems are probably much shorter they
would they will grow on the order of
days to maybe a week or two depending on
what model system you're using and how
large you're trying to have it grow too
but typically in the organoid space
protocols lasts anywhere from several
weeks potentially to many months before
they're actually sort of at an end point
where they're useful for a say our
potentially useful for a say and so this
is done to help promote the maturation
of different cell types especially if
you're talking with pluripotent stem
cells but this the take home really is
that because these are really long
protocols it's really important to plan
ahead to make sure you have everything
you need to sustain you your culture
through the term of the of the
experiment so that you you don't sort of
go oh I've been culturing for a month
I've got one more month to go and you
find out you're in-between orders and
and suddenly you might not have material
for the next media change although that
that sounds a little bit pandering it is
really not meant to it's just meant to
emphasize that in these line protocols
I mean planning as always is really
important but they're really thinking
planning maybe a little longer term than
then one may be a little more customed
to doing another part of this also has
to do with what we call it earlier the
less common culture formats the use of
you know roller bottles or mini
bioreactors or spinner flasks or the use
of orbital shakers maybe not always in
the form of flats like shown here
sometimes their orbital shakers that you
would put in your incubator on which you
know it's a flat platform so you can
like various types of dishes in there
for agitation to help with the feeding
and long-term growth of your organized
muddled system so the reason why this is
certainly something to plan for is
because these things take up different
amounts of space in in a typical cell
culture incubator then you're then
simply putting plates on on a shelf will
typically do so the space required to
grow these is certainly something
different that that definitely requires
planning for especially if this is not
the only thing your lab is doing if you
want to maintain space for other
experiments that maybe aren't using
these sorts of less common culture
formats you know it does require
planning ahead and of course working
with your colleagues the other important
feature to remember here with with
respect to the length of these cultures
is that these really long or extended
culture times it really enhances or
compounds the risk of contamination and
I know in talking to lots of customers
and collaborators who work in various
types of models although I'm sure people
don't always like to admit to it you
know the longer you are doing something
in cell culture you're taking things out
of the incubator many many times
you're risking contamination just goes
up and when you're investing the the
amount of time it takes to grow an
organize for example to a useful end
point and considering the investment of
resources needed to grow these models
contamination is something that one
should take extremely seriously and
really maybe take extra precautions to
guard against because if you if you go
three months into a protocol and it gets
contaminated you know you kinda have to
start over and so it's it's definitely
something to keep on top of mind and the
other piece I I guess that that's
important to call it with respect to the
length of culture is that and with
respect to planning is that doing
iterative analysis on a given system
when the protocol is long also means
your entire study is going to take a lot
of time and so with that in mind you
know remembering you know maybe
staggering cultures might be one way to
do it so that you've got multiple
experiments going that are just delayed
by a fixed time so that you've got
multiple repeats that are sort of coming
to an end at various times so that
you're not starting from scratch every
time you want you need new samples for
analysis and so although some of this
may sound a little bit doom and gloom
and it really should not because because
these model systems are really
interesting and are allowing people to
to study things in a way they haven't
done before but it is also important to
remember to choose the best system or
the system that's best suited to your
needs and it's important to ask yourself
how complex of a model do you really
need so it may be that in some cases if
the traditional 2d model system will
still get you to the end point where you
would like to go it may be that you need
a 3d cell model system and then with
respect to 3d models there are
considerations to be had with well how
many cell types do I really need in this
model do I need a neural organoid that
contains or models as much of the brain
as possible or maybe I just need a
region specific model system that might
be a little easier to grow a little more
control and get you to the end point
where you want to go and also
considerations you know between adult
model systems and pluripotency our PSC
derived model systems the level of
maturation of cells maybe you know
something that that one has to reckon
with and decide you know how mature is
enough for for your study and those
sorts of considerations
and so with that I really just want to
end with a very brief summary
so again 3d some models are very
exciting and and they're growing in
population in popularity for a very good
reason however they are very reagent
intensive and as such they they do tend
to be much more expensive than
traditional tuning cultures and they do
come with long and somewhat complex
workflows and so all of this kind of
culminates in the idea that it's really
important to to choose the right model
for for what it is you're interested in
studying but again the reason why people
and why a lot of cell biology is moving
toward 3d cell models is the desire to
generate better models in order to
generate better data as it relates to
studying whether it be human development
disease etiology predicting drug
responses identifying new therapeutics
using 3d cell model systems in any one
of those ways in either regenerative
medicine or perhaps in and precision
medicine you know 3d cell models really
are an exciting new tool in the cell
biologists toolkit for addressing many
of these these questions and so with
that I'd like to thank you all for your
attention and I'd like to close with
reminder that we are now able to open it
up live for questions and answers thank
you
thank you Mark for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button mark will answer as many
questions as time permits so let's get
started the first question is what are
some of the differences between
pluripotent stem cell models and adult
tissue derived models
so this is a good question so so
pluripotent stem cell models obviously
are made from embryonic or IPS C cells
and these are different from the adult
tissue drive models in that these cells
have a broader differentiation capacity
meaning they can give rise to a wider
variety of cell types given the right
signals and and culture environment then
the adult tissue derived models can
where these are more restricted to cell
fates that are typically found in the
organ type from which the or tissue type
from which these progenitor cells were
derived and even more so most of these
models tend to only recapitulate the
epithelial compartment of a given organ
system so so what that means then is
that they tend to have fewer cell types
now it is possible in some situations if
you can figure it the right growth media
to to add in some of the missing cell
types but the the pluripotent stem cell
models are sort of able to generate more
of these cell types perhaps
simultaneously given the right culture
conditions however pluripotent stem
cells also are still ply their the field
in general probably are supplied with
the ability to generate a fully mature
fully functional cell from from a
pluripotent stem cell quite frequently
people will relate to how there's still
a fetal characteristic to to the cell as
a way of relying you know that they're
still not fully mature and so
pluripotent cell derived 3d models you
know have that same issue however
putting them into 3d is reported to help
speed up or help improve the level of
maturity and function that these cells
can achieve in vitro at least within a
relative amount of time extended cell
cultures may may also help more or
better maturity
cells but you know we're not always at
the had the ability to call for these
four six eight nine ten months at a time
to for that to happen
adult tissue derived models tend to be
more mature because they they're already
derived from an adult tissue so it seems
to be that they've already you know
through the course of normal development
I've already passed through all these
stages and progressed into you know an
adult tissue cell and so these these
seems to do a better job at then
generating complex models that have more
mature cell types
now mark can you expand a little on the
challenges and limitations of using
matrigel or similar technologies sure so
as I mentioned during the talk a number
of 3d cell models require the use of an
extracellular matrix mimic or mimetic
and a lot of people or a lot of these
methods were built using a basement
membrane extract called Maitre gel and
there are other similar technologies
that exist out there gel tracks and call
tracks are some of the other ones that
if they're useful in making these these
organized models in particular but but
also some steroid models so some of the
limitations to these materials is that
they are temperature sensitive once they
start to warm up they start to to jail
or polymerize fairly quickly which means
working with them takes you know you
have to take extra care to be able to
work with them and so you know working
with cells on ice and in a flow hood and
those sorts of things just creates a
little bit of an inconvenience really
and and may add some risk of
contamination or add some contamination
risks that one want would want to be
fully aware of so you know these sorts
of problems are some of the challenges
in addition to that these materials
they're derived from a mouse sarcoma so
I know frequently people question how
relevant of a material it is given that
the composition of the material can vary
from lots a lot to the extent that it
requires a lot testing for for one's
experiments so that they could then
procure you know a relatively large
amount from the same a lot that
functions for their needs in order to be
able to reproduce ly reproducibly
generate their data so these sort of
undefined components or sometimes
inconsistent components of these
materials are certainly a limitation of
it and although you can probably control
the the stiffness of the material
which is a feature that I know some
folks are interested in in terms of
trying to recreate an extracellular
environment in vitro that looks more
like the the ECM environment in both its
biochemical and biophysical properties
in the organ and vivo so although with
you you can do probably some tuning of
stiffness of these materials being able
to modify them with with other peptides
and and also retrieving cells from from
these materials is not a trivial
exercise
how do you harvest or transfer spheroids
from a 96-well you bought a plate the
short answer is very carefully so
depending on how big your spheroid gets
you know it'd be pretty tedious to do
this one well at a time but you know
some some handheld things like
disposable sterile transfer pipettes can
be done to do that I tend to use the
multi-channel pipettes the same way if
I'm using it for doing media changes as
I described earlier we're using a
multi-channel pipette to to remove just
maybe 50% or 75% of the media and
allowing the spheroid to stay on the
bottom the difference would be for
transferring the spheroids
I would use a pipette or a multi-channel
preferably with wide board tips so that
the spheroids can can be aspirated up
into the tip more efficiently and then
transferred to to some other vessel for
for downstream manipulations
and it looks like we have time for one
more question how do I know if the
spheroid or organoid I made is any good
that's also a very good question and one
that doesn't have an easy answer the you
know at the end of the day it's really
going to require sort of testing to find
out one you know what what's the the how
healthy is the sample I mean do I just
have a ball of mostly dead cells and you
know what impact is that going to have
on my model it is big enough is it too
large does it have the cell types that
are relevant
there's just unfortunately you know sort
of no standard way of knowing what you
know if it's exactly what you need with
in advance of of doing that sort of
testing but but you know what one should
probably do and again this is probably
somewhat obvious but given the the
length of these protocols and the you
know the increase amount of reagent
reagents that that are usually required
to generate these it's also it's
probably good practice to try and
identify some quality control steps in
your method so that you can routinely
sample you know acquire a sample of your
spheroids or organoids quickly monitor
them by either imaging for for their
proportion of dead cells or maybe doing
a qPCR panel of a few number of genes to
make sure your your cell types are
represented or you know if there are
functional markers that you can identify
in that way to make sure that that there
that they are expressed at the time
points in the protocol when you would
anticipate them being expressed or being
present it really is just a way of
trying to identify as early as possible
in your protocol whether or not things
are progressing in the manner that you
want them to progress in so that one you
either continue to culture or if you
look at your gene
freshen and you find you have you know
what what you feel is an unacceptable
level of off-target differentiation in
two cell types that are not important
for your model then you've probably
reached a decision point where you can
stop and start over
and and try again
again to thank dr. mark Kennedy for his
presentation I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand series
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration we would like
to thank our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through September of 2019 flapper to
alert you via email and it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you will
now be directed to register for part
three on 3d culture and analysis until
next time goodbye